- WELL, THIS SUCKS,
MALLOY.
I CAN'T BELIEVE NO ONE
WANTS TO MEET ME.
THERE'S EVEN A LINE
TO SEE THE FATTIES
FROM
FILIPINO FOOT FETISH 5!
♪
[camera shutter clicking]
- THAT WAS A SURPRISINGLY
SOLID FILM, DESPITE THE FACT
THAT YOU DIDN'T REALIZE
IT WAS A PREQUEL TILL THE END.
- I'M A JOKE.
I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU
TALKED ME INTO COMING HERE.
MY LEGACY IS DEAD.
- CHEER UP, WOODY.
THESE PORN NERDS
ARE JUST CHEAP.
AUTOGRAPHS NOW
ONLY $10.
$1.00 AUTOGRAPHS.
[thud]
OKAY, NO ONE LOVES YOU.
- JESUS DOES!
- NOT AFTER HE SAW
THE REXERECTION IV:
EASTER [bleep]DAY.
- LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
IT IS MY PLEASURE
TO INTRODUCE THE BIGGEST
PORN STAR IN THE WORLD,
THE GOD OF ROD,
THE MASTER ASS BLASTER,
THE SHOE-IN FOR THIS YEAR'S
BONEY AWARD,
DUKE DICK!
[cheers and applause]
- HEY, THOSE ARE MY MOVES!
THAT'S MY NAVAJO CHAP SLAP
AND MY INVERTED CLAM!
[gasps]
AND THAT'S MY MR. BELVEDERE!
- YO! DUKE DICK
IN THE HIT ZONE!
WHAT TIME IS IT?
- IT'S TIME TO BUST ASS!
- AND THAT'S
MY CATCHPHRASE!
- NOW, WHO WANTS TO SEE DUKE
DO HIS FAMOUS MOVE?
THE DUKE ROCKET!
[cheers and applause]
- STOP RIGHT THERE!
- SOMEONE GET
THIS QUEEN OFFSTAGE
BEFORE THE DUKE
GETS FILLED WITH RAGE!
- YOU STOLE ALL OF MY MOVES,
ASSHOLE!
- ASSHOLE? MY ASSHOLE HAS WON
FIVE BONEY AWARDS!
SHOW SOME RESPECT, SON!
- OH, I AIN'T YOUR SON,
HOMBRE.
I'M REX [bleep] ERECTION!
- REX ERECTION
WAS MY HERO
UNTIL HE TOLD ME
I'D NEVER MAKE IT.
- WHAT THE--
"DEAR DUKE,
YOU GOT A SMALL TOOL.
STAY IN SCHOOL.
REX."
- WELL, I SHOWED YOU.
NOW I'M ON TOP, AND YOU'RE
ALL WASHED UP, OLD MAN.
- NOT FOR LONG, 'CAUSE YOU
KNOW WHAT I'M GONNA DO?
- I DON'T KNOW.
SKYPE WITH YOUR GRANDKIDS?
- NO, I'M GONNA
COME OUT OF RETIREMENT,
I'M GONNA MAKE MY OWN MOVIE,
I'M GONNA WIN THAT BONEY,
AND THEN I'M GONNA SHOVE IT UP
YOUR AWARD-WINNING ASSHOLE!
- YEAH, RIGHT.
WHAT DIRECTOR WOULD TOUCH
YOUR WASHED-UP WHITE ASS?
- I WILL.
- DUDE, A HAIRY
LITTLE WOODLAND CREATURE
CAN'T DIRECT A MOVIE.
- UH, WHAT ABOUT
PETER JACKSON?
- OKAY,
I STAND CORRECTED.